hello and welcome to the cheeky science
show where in this video i'm going to
tell you about a recent study that has
literally just come out
that has shown real-time communication
with lucid dreamers
so for the majority of times when we
dream we fail to realize that any of our
experiences
is merely a dream on the other hand
someone who is
lucid dreaming are able to be aware that
they are asleep
and dreaming but understanding lucid
dreams and while
understanding dreams in general has
always been a very difficult thing to do
mainly due to the fact that well you're
asleep and so dream reports that are
given from the dreamer
after waking are used instead however
these can be distorted
or fragmented due to generally a poor
ability to
recollect what exactly happens during a
dream so to circumvent this ambiguity
the best way is to actually get a
real-time measurement of what's
happening
during that lucid dream state well
that's exactly what the researchers
behind this paper were trying to do
and guess what they achieved it so how
did they achieve it
well firstly they needed to find lucid
dreamers and so lucid dreaming is a
notoriously rare phenomenon
and can rarely be summoned at will i
mean i've even tried myself
and i failed so if anyone's got any tips
please do let me know
and so that's one difficulty the
researchers faced but they were able to
find lucid dreamers and they split them
into three different categories
experienced lucid dreamers healthy
people with minimal prior experience who
were trained to lose a dream
and then thirdly they had one patient
with narcolepsy and that is a
neurological disorder characterized
by frequent lucid dreaming but i suppose
the more interesting question is how are
they able to do this communication
process
and what were the data results well
several different methods were used and
it was also validated by having
independent scientific teams in france
germany the netherlands
and the usa however in each case sensory
stimulation was used
to convey questions to the dreaming
participants
and training was given to the
participants prior to sleep with the
same type of sensory stimulation that
was
used during the sleep with the important
point that the participants didn't know
what specific questions would be
presented to them during sleep
so that the communication subsequently
undertaken
during the sleep was always novel and
the other former training that the
participants required
was training such that they could
communicate back to the experimenter
what their answer was
and the way that they did this was using
physiological signals
based on facial or eye movements now i'm
not sure how much this is making sense
so the best thing to do is actually show
you some data
so the first example they give is a 19
year old american participant
who had previously experienced only two
lucid dreams
and so during this 90 minutes nap that
he was undertaking
at the beginning of entering rem sleep
which is rapid eye movement
they presented him with a spoken math
question eight
minus six within three seconds he
responded with two
left right eye movements as i explained
previously they were trained to respond
and communicate back to the experimenter
with either facial movements or with
eye movements and so as you can see in
this figure
the two left right eye movements happen
shortly after the question 8-6 was asked
so the participant gave the correct
answer in response to the question
and as you can see the experimenters
actually asked this question
twice and both times they got the
correct response but the interesting
thing is what the patient recollected on
awakening
when the experimenter asked whether he
remembered hearing any of the mass
problems
how many he answered and what he
answered the subject reported
i think i had three problems i answered
two
for all of them but i don't remember
what the first one was
i just remember the last one was eight
minus six
so the idea is that in this study
they've been combining both this
communication in real time with the
dream reports to have
two modes of validation the second
example that i want to show you is with
a 35 year old german participant
who was an experienced lucid dreamer
this time however
he was presented visual stimuli
consisting of alternating colors and
corresponding to a morse coded math
problem
four minus zero as you can see here the
participant produced the correct answer
for using again this left right eye
movement
the interesting thing with the dream
report from this participant is how he
received the signal
the participant had this to say i was
alone in the room
when the light started flickering i
recognized this as the flashing signal
from the outside
and reported the answer for with eye
signals now these are just two examples
of successful
two-way communication attempts given by
the experimenters with the lucid
dreamers
as you can see in this table here 18.4
percent
of the times that they get the correct
response
when signal verified lucid dreaming was
occurring
and the communication was attempted
majority of the times
there wasn't a response or the response
was ambiguous
and the remainder were incorrect
responses now obviously there's still a
lot of work to be done to investigate
this further
but from the examples provided it can be
seen that there's some evidence
that advanced cognitive abilities can be
engaged in dreams
such as the ability to do these
mathematical calculations
secondly it shows how meaning can be
delivered during sleep
and can actually influence stream
content and this idea has been famously
portrayed in christopher nolan's film
inception
which is have to say one of my favorite
films anyway i want to conclude with
what the authors say at the end of this
paper that with the advent of
interactive dreaming which is their new
approach demonstrated in this paper
of the communication between
experimenters
and dreamers has new opportunities for
gaining real-time information about
dreaming
and for modifying the course of a dream
this could usher in a new era of
investigations
into sleep and into the enigmatic
cognitive dimensions of sleep
now that's pretty cool so i hope you've
learned something in this video
i want to give a shout out to my patreon
supporters
and thanks for listening